roses es la última advertencia de rusia
a las fuerzas occidentales que apoyan a
ucrania esto fue lo que dijo el ministro
de relaciones exteriores sérguei lávrov
cuando se le preguntó en una entrevista
transmitida por la televisión estatal
sobre la amenaza de una tercera guerra
mundial y un potencial conflicto nuclear
los riesgos ahora son considerables no
me gustaría elevar esos riesgos
artificialmente a muchos les gustaría
eso el peligro es serio real y no
debemos subestimarlos
lávrov también dijo que ve a la otan
esencialmente involucrada en una guerra
de poder con rusia mediante el
suministro de armas a ucrania de todos
los aliados ninguno ha enviado más ayuda
militar que eeuu que ha entregado a
ucrania más de tres mil millones de
dólares desde que comenzó la invasión
los envíos han incluido drones tácticos
sistemas antiaéreos y cañones de
artillería howitt ser de largo alcance
durante el fin de semana en kiev el
secretario de defensa lloyd austin y el
secretario de estado- anthony blinken
prometieron 700 millones de dólares más
y eeuu parece dispuesto a seguir
ofreciendo apoyo
diría que es coherente con nuestra
opinión la del presidente y la del
secretario hasta que haremos todo lo
posible para hacer retroceder las
aspiraciones del presidente putin de
anexarse a ucrania para hacerse cargo de
su integridad territorial su soberanía y
aspiraciones
eeuu organiza una cumbre de unos 40
países en alemania este martes para
discutir el envío de más armas a ucrania
mientras tanto rusia ha estado atacando
las instalaciones de almacenamiento y
las líneas ferroviarias utilizadas para
transportar suministros diciendo que
considera que los envíos de armas
extranjeras son objetivos legítimos